the European Commission's top priority
is jobs and growth to support that
agenda we need to unlock investment in
Europe's companies and infrastructure
and that's where the capital markets
union a single market for all 28 member
states comes in
linking savings with growth it will help
money flow throughout the EU to
businesses that need money to grow our
action plan will remove barriers that
stop money in one country being invested
in another so that it can be put to work
to support Europe's businesses in
particular our SMEs
stronger capital markets will complement
banks as a source of financing giving
businesses more options and making
Europe's financial system more stable
CMU will help companies get financing
whatever their size so that more
European entrepreneurs can grow and
prosper here in Europe instead of having
to go to the United States for savers
our action plan should lead to more
investment opportunities helping people
to save and plan for their old age over
time this action plan will help make
Europe a more attractive place for
companies and investors from all over
the world and help create a European
economy that is more dynamic and more
prosperous
you